hi my name is Tom and I'm 18 and I'm
studying further maths and i was
wondering with a discovery of the
breakdown of matter antimatter symmetry
at the lacs and having implications on
your study of the early universe hi Tom
your question about the breakdown of the
symmetry between matter and antimatter
is one of the toughest questions of
modern science astronomers can tell you
that the universe does not have anti
galaxies we would know if there were
anti galaxies out there because they
would be boundaries between the
antimatter regions and the ordinary
matter regions so we know from astronomy
that there is a somehow a fundamental
difference between matter and antimatter
nevertheless the particle scientists
have been studying this for a long time
and we can't really tell what is the
difference between matter and antimatter
so they look like they're just exact
opposites and and they ought to behave
the same so the big mystery is why did
the universe in the Big Bang or whatever
started this whole expansion that we're
in why did it give us only matter so
we're looking for the fundamental reason
for asymmetry and we certainly hoping
that the Large Hadron Collider will help
us understand that by revealing some
small difference between particles and
their antiparticles